going back to uh what you're talking
about here the greatest of all time you
said rick is at the top ric flair hawk
is in the conversation he said all this
stuff but let's go to peak who peaked
the most for one year two year three
years like
that's what i'm saying so i know how
yeah they'll say the greatest boxer of
all time is ali right but the greatest
peak of all time isn't it tyson like
yeah so who would be the greatest peak
would you put goldberg at the top i
would say him or austin because they
were so hot rock the wrong kind of
crazy you know uh but was really like if
austin and
mcmahon
don't have that feud
where basically like giving the finger
to you to your boss you know and people
love that
like steve changed the game the nwo took
it like you never would have thought wcw
could have competed with wwe but when
us you know once we did nwo
we kicked their ass for like bishop has
a show uh um a podcast called 83 weeks
in 83 weeks we kicked their ass
and then that whole boston and mcmahon
thing happened and it started to shift
to tide again
you know and and that's where how did
that happen how did the friction between
the two happen what caused it what was
the tipping point
the vince was is probably the you know
maybe the greatest heal of all time
because he he he fully commits
and
he was not afraid to have you know have
austin in this scenario shine him and it
was really you know it was it's just
great television and uh you know
everybody wants to not everybody but
many people want to knock their boss out
you know
not true over here over here
don't put that in a set
when you say heel this is someone who
plays the villain yes right yes
walk us through that because i assume
most people want to be the hero no the
hogan the good guy no you're saying most
people want to play the heel every
pretty much every guy who starts yeah
wants to be the heel really fun to be
jay are you in it's fun it's easy to get
people to hate you
it's really hard
to get people to love you
you've got to really be vulnerable
uh you've gotta you've gotta show
something that they can identify with
for me it was
the underdog
you know
jim ross called me the greatest
overachiever of all time and in my hall
of fame speech i said to be an
overachiever you must first be an over
believer
and it's so true
when i was inducted to jake in the hall
of fame and you have to understand
before jake moved into my place and
anybody who's never seen the
resurrection of jake the snake
it's on amazon prime along with another
documentary we just put out called
relentless
um
but it's dark because it's addiction but
it will make you laugh
it will make you cry
most of all it'll inspire you because
jake just didn't burn bridges as we call
that you know
jake nuked them like he was never gonna
take he had said so many bad things
about wwe and vince mcmahon
you know again
when you're addicted you do things that
you don't do when you're beating the
addiction what was he addicted to
booze pills coke crack
you know i mean everything
and because jake helped me
to like i don't ever get without dusty
rose there's a diamond dallas page
without jake there's no three-time world
champion without the both of those guys
guiding me when i needed them
i'm not a hall of famer but i was
because i
being 35 like i said earlier was the
hardest thing i ever did hitting that
mat in the beginning but it was the best
thing never happened to me because i was
smarter than i would have been at 35
you know what i mean so i should just
say at 25 right you know 25 i i would
have done a lot of stupid things
and
i don't think i ever would have had the
career i had
and it was pretty in everything that i
do it's like when jake comes into the
crib and i call it the accountability
[ __ ]
um
[Music]
when he comes in there
the number one thing i want him to
understand
is
you are
the story you tell yourself
that inner voice
you know we all have it you know if it's
i this is funny because i'm preparing
for a speech i'm going to do uh for
someone georgia's corporation
and um
about 10 years ago i heard that harvard
did
um
did a uh
uh
one of the things where they get a group
of people together focus group focus
group and
they
i heard that 72 percent
of the people say things that we worry
about never happen so i thought oh i'm
preparing for this i'm going to actually
i'm going to look it up i want to see
that study
harvard never did a study on the maureen
thing uh
but
cornell did
but it wasn't 72
it was 85
following people over an extended period
of time
85 percent of the things they worry
about
never happen and it gets better than
that
of that 15
79
handled the adversity
way better than they thought they would
and many of them said i'm glad it
happened because i learned something
from it
so really
97
according to this study by a kind of
decent school you know cornell
um
ninety percent of things we never
never worry we worry about never happen
so again jake let's tell change the
story
like that you tell yourself like when he
came in
and it was more like he was waiting to
die and when someone died he was pissed
it wasn't him
he never had dreams anymore because you
were there's so much fog on your brain
from the coke and the crack and the
booze and the pills
you know
so when he when he got there the first
thing i do and the same thing and we
talked about this earlier the show we're
filming right now called
change or die
and the first thing i do is change what
they eat
like
no gluten
no dairy
no gmos
organic
or
what god created
you know because
when what i get people eating it affects
their mindset is they're so beat up in
heart jake and scott were so beat up and
i couldn't believe how bad a shape they
were in physically
you change the food they eat
because our food sucks
in this country it's
it's criminal what the lobbyists and the
big corporations have done to our food
just watch food inc genetic neglect our
gmo omg
and then you'll have a little bit of an
insight these are all things i make
people watch and things they have to do
to be a part of what i'm doing so jake
and those guys so now they change what
they eat
they already start feeling better
now my workouts my ddp yoga or i call
ddpy why because i want people to stop
calling it just [ __ ] yoga because
it's not
it's yoga rehab old school calisthenics
and something i call dynamic resistance
which is flexing and engaging
as you're moving
so
just like lifting weights
time under tension
so what happens
every time you flex or engage a muscle
your heart
has to beat faster get the blood to the
muscle
so what ends up happening is you're
getting a cardiovascular
workout
breaking up scar tissue and creating
mobility
strengthening your core a different
level all with minimal joint impact now
you guys i've been sitting here for the
last hour
when i blew oh he's getting up y'all
watch out wait wait
can you get a camera so you can get uh
get up get a mic closer to your ddp okay
so it's good you can lift it up alright
so
when i blew my back out this
was my flexibility yeah you know i've
been sitting here the whole time right
this is cold
damn he's all the way down insane
but flexibility 65 years old 66. hey but
who's counting you're looking great
crochet core balance core strength is a
whole different animal be able to stand
here and talk to you and grab either one
of my feet
and grab it and pull it over my head
[ __ ] and have a conversation with you at
six foot four
228 pounds of twisted steel and sex
appeal
[Laughter]
that that's and 66 years young
your wife must love that move whatever
that was my wife makes me look like i'm
not pliable at all
she's amazing and she's broken her back
twice i've heard
so
my my point is with the program
what happened to me when i was wrestling
with kevin nash and it was a tag match
and kevin picked me up for the power
bomb that he does
he's six foot ten legit
and he's throwing me trying to get me to
go flat
but when i hit it wasn't that bump
it was the proverbial straw that broke
the camel's back i ruptured my l4 and l5
so god gave us this incredible spine
right in between are these amazing
things called this but they're like
shock absorbers
well take a jelly donut
and do that
now
she becomes bone on bone
and i don't know how i did it all i know
is so much of this
reaching and stretching and
strengthening i'm constantly creating
traction
because
i'm trying to pull those bones off each
other
i was told by three different spine
specialists when this happened that i
was never wrestle again
i just did sign the multi-million dollar
big deal and i'd never gotten paid
before that
so the money was a factor
but it was more the dream
i just got there and now i mean i'm as
high as you can be i'm up there with
everybody according to pro wrestling
illustrated 97 and 98 i'm number four in
the world
austin's one i'm four
he's 35
he's 30 32.
i'm 42.
crazy so
i'm i'm obviously i'm in the
conversation of the top 10 easily
and
for me i got to get back there i just
got to get back there because i got to
prove you can do this
in less than three months
i'm that guy in less than three months
in less than three months but i didn't
do it
no 20 minutes a day
i started with 20 minutes a day
twice a day i was doing yoga in the
beginning in the first three weeks i
felt a significant difference i was like
wow this is really helping
i had to figure out modifications all my
workouts are surrounded around
modifications like i said bedflex starts
off in bed
chair force
sits in a chair
stand strong holds on to the chair
so you can create balance again and
strength and get up and get down and it
just helps you
make it easier so you can get to that
next spot of breaking up the scar tissue
and creating the mobility like i said
less than three months i'm back in the
ring at 42 they said my career is over
at 43 i'm the world champ now understand
whether and i put it like this like
world championship that's our oscar
okay u.s title intercontinental that's
our emmy you know and so forth like
there's
like you're drawing you're bringing
people to the crowd like those belts
all these fans have them because it's
like it's
it's part of the nostalgia that goes
with it
and
it's you know as far as my program
it's just for me in the beginning for
years and i started sharing it with some
of my buddies and in 2004 i said
i'm going to make i'm going to turn this
into something so me and my business
partner dr craig aaron we wrote a book
on it we called it yoga for regular guys
back then that's what i was calling it
and
for years you know i made a dvd series
up uh and it was just the workouts and
then
i put together a whole program with the
food and you know the um
the uh the inspirational part
and still didn't go anywhere it took
eight years
to become an overnight success
and doesn't it usually work that way
though by the way that's that's how it
does it's like oh it's like the 10 000
hour thing yep you know
and in this scenario arthur borman's
video went viral and this was a disabled
vet that i'd helped it
was um five foot six
297 pounds couldn't walk without the
knee braces back bracing to wrap around
keynes
he starts every single person who got my
program it was just dvds i would send
him an email there was no auto send
today i do have auto send but back then
there was no autos
i sent it i cut paste put their name on
it sent it to him and i said am i trying
to sell you anything i want to thank you
i call people all the time who get my
program they'll say hey hey i was uh
jenny there
uh yeah i was speaking i go ah this is
ddp
who
i go
ddp diamond
it's the most entertaining part of what
we do
let me ask you something while we're on
this topic
you've always been a fit guy yeah i mean
this guy was in the army he was a
bodybuilder i don't know if you've got
these pictures but this guy's i mean
we're great you guys are the same size
pretty much
but lately you've been working out more
than ever you're getting up at 6 00 a.m
and you're doing hardcore workouts yeah
i mean he's telling you all the benefits
he's 66 he's all he's bending over like
how much better do you feel since you've
changed
your you know physical workout regimen
every morning your life night and day
night and day i mean it's not even a
question about what it does to your body
if i don't work out i just don't feel
better
it's very weird to display if you look
at that picture right there look at that
guy to the left look at that guy i'm 6'1
135 to the left and then to the right
i'm in the army that's my army barracks
on the bottom
click on that one what about that
look at the pictures it's all flex
magazine it's all angel tevez go down a
little bit
this one dude pat are you kidding me
dude no that's right valley total
fitness culver city in the basement you
were ready for the ring
hey brother you listen here right now
but but to do what he just did
at 66 years old yeah i'm 43 to be able
to do that in 23 years right that's like
pinnacle i the only thing i know what to
do is to be 43 years old i only know 43
and less than that i have no clue what
it is at 66. so that's just major profit
and respect brother for you to do what
you're doing
uh the way you the way you just stood up
and did that so so you helped that man
out you helped a lot of different guys
out to change their lifestyle uh with
the drugs you were talking about earlier
when he said jake i would look at him he
just said he didn't have another dream
just there's no other dream that he was
looking forward to every time somebody
died he was hoping it's him right so you
helped shape that mindset of somebody
like him to look forward to the dream is
that kind of what you did well
he had a really really really really
really dark childhood
and he carried that and it probably
helped him do some really great
interviews later
um
but we were doing when i proved jake
into my house and then later scott as
well
um
everybody thought i was crazy like i was
bringing addicts like everybody gave up
on both of them
kevin nash didn't give up on scott hall
but besides that everybody given up on
both of those guys
and when jake came in
i mean we got interviewed by deadline
and you know in yahoo sports and hbo
sports came like everyone was like they
were so blown away by the story
and
i didn't look at it as bringing an attic
into my house i look at it as bringing
it to my brother who literally and both
of those guys were very instrumental in
my career having the career i had
and jake would when he get on his thing
he'd start talking about this dark [ __ ]
again and i looked at the guy and i said
can you hold on a second i just want to
talk to him for a minute and i pulled
him in the next room
i said bro
i get you have this past
but if you keep holding on to this pass
we're never going to get by that i go
what about all the amazing things you
have eight kids
and right now
four of them are talking to you again
that's a big deal right he goes of
course it is i go yeah
nobody would book you for more than 500
bucks
at the time he was making like 2 500.
i go you're up five times in your
booking fee because people know they can
count on you
what about all the amazing things that
are happening in your life
and
he's just started changing it then he
would walk up the people because he's
doing my program right
and he's feeling so much better in the
beginning he's got to use the chair he's
got to use this he's got to use that
all of a sudden he doesn't use any of
that
and he's so much stronger has so much
more confidence that's the number one
thing that ddpy builds
confidence
because people can't do that in the
beginning bringing their foot over their
head
but then they can if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you